bonjour à toutes et à tous au 1er
janvier 2016 la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines change de
visage mais surtout de frontières une
superficie qui double presque entraînant
avec elles l'arrivée de nouveaux grands
groupes des pmi et pme prometteuses mais
aussi des universités des grandes écoles
et des nouveaux commerces à quelques
mois de la date officielle de cet
élargissement
je vous propose de faire le point sur
les atouts économiques de ce nouveau
territoire
vous me suivez
et
les ambitions de saint quentin en
yvelines sont immenses à l'image de son
agrandissement
dès 2016 cinq communes feront leur
entrée dans l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise les clayes-sous-bois
coignières villepreux maurepas et
plaisir au total 230 mille habitants
répartis sur cent vingt kilomètres
carrés de verdure de forêt et cours
d'eau qui donne aux territoires un côté
champêtre où il fait bon vivre mais que
l'on ne s'y trompe pas saint quentin en
yvelines est avant tout une
agglomération résolument moderne et
attractive qui compte presque autant
d'étudiants que d'entreprises en effet
16600 société en telus domicile sur ce
territoire
et parmi elles des leaders mondiaux
incroyablement logique plus tôt car les
atouts pour s'installer ne manquent pas
pour faire réussir une boîte il faut des
moyens il faut des des chercheurs il
faut bien sûr des les meilleurs produits
il fait donc on être à être en rapport
avec le monde entier vous avez quand
même ici une un espace d'innovation je
voulais 10 places et huitième au monde
c'est la silicon valley française
vous êtes beaucoup d'atouts pour que
tout le monde ait envie de travailler
mieux de de chercher encore mieux de
sortir les nouveaux produits que ce soit
dans le numérique ce soit dans la ville
du futur on travaille sur la ville du
futur ici on travaille sur le l'avion du
futur sol et sur la voiture du futur sur
la pédagogie du futur sur l'université
du futur donc à beaucoup bien sûr de
recherche et de
donc sur ces axes extrêmement prometteur
pour l'avenir de 2,51 et de ce pays
zodiac
atos achète thyssenkrupp jc decaux
ils sont six mille cinq cents nouveaux
établissements à intégrer le territoire
élargi grâce à cette concentration
d'entreprises saint-quentin-en-yvelines
conforte sa place de deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien juste
après la défense
un titre que la casse qui compte bien
conserver alors ici on bichonne les
créateurs du développement économique
l'entreprise c'est la solution faut bien
la remettre au centre qu'elles soient
mieux respectés mieux aimer mais dès
qu'on lui simplifient la vie qu'on l'ait
d'avoir accès plus facilement aux
compétences aux formations à l'argent
pour se développer au laboratoire pour
la recherche
l'histoire du leader mondial du mobilier
urbain jc decaux s'écrit depuis 50 ans à
plaisir l'une des nouvelles villes en 30
et pour cette multinationale forcément
il est toujours agréable de se sentir
bien accueilli c'est important pour une
entreprise comme jc decaux de sentir que
l'entreprise est au coeur du territoire
et je crois qu'un des meilleurs exemples
c'est l'organisation
cette première soirée des entrepreneurs
en novembre qui est pour nous
véritablement une opportunité de
rencontrer un grand nombre d'acteurs
notamment économique du territoire
c'est un réflexe pour nous de regarder
autour de nous avant d'aller chercher
des compétences plus éloignés et c'est
pourquoi nous travaillons au quotidien
avec un grand nombre de très petites
entreprises ou de plus grosses issue est
implantée sur le territoire afin de
rester dans une relation de proximité
parmi les autres entreprises de renom
qui intègre le territoire avec
l'élargissement on trouve la maison
lenôtre et son école professionnelle
installée depuis 1971 à plaisir le
traiteur réputé pour ses entre eux mais
haut de gamme a toujours mis un point
d'honneur à transmettre sa passion et
son savoir faire
pour le directeur de l'école ce
rapprochement est une opportunité
il espère bien concrétiser des rapports
gagnant gagnant avec les entreprises
environnantes
la relation qu'on peut avoir avec toutes
les entreprises locales c'est vraiment
une relation de partenaires c'est à dire
que s'ils veulent avoir de la formation
sur mesure on est capable de leur
apporter c'est à dire quand on peut se
déplacer dans leurs locaux et faire la
formation sur mesure où si leur
personnel que ce soit les pâtissiers
l'écuyer veulent avoir du
perfectionnement sur un domaine bien
précis
on les accueille très volontiers à
l'école et on peut aussi proposer aux
différentes entreprises éventuellement
des team building éventuellement des
cours de cuisine où les personnes
peuvent venir ici et c'est un cours
magistral
on peut faire des cures participatif
démonstratif à tout est possible et
c'est vraiment l'intérêt d'être proche
de toutes ces entreprises avec ses
bachelor master ou cours de
perfectionnement dédié aux
professionnels et amateurs de la cuisine
de luxe l'école lenôtre attire chaque
année plus de 3000 étudiants des
sessions de formation pouvant aller
jusqu'à six mois qui accueille 60 %
d'étudiants étrangers venant
essentiellement d'asie
une aubaine pour le territoire selon le
chef les hôtes et je pense que la maison
lenôtre est particulièrement l'école
note peut être vraiment un moteur pour
l'économie de cette région des îles
dessous ce territoire pour la bonne et
simple raison c'est que c'est une marque
aujourd'hui et un ans qu'est reconnue en
france mais aussi dans le monde et donc
les gens viennent consomment sur place
il reste un mois mais peuvent rester
aussi si moi je pense que c'est un moyen
de faire évoluer l'économie de l'argent
attractivité c'est sans doute le
meilleur qualificatif que l'on pourrait
donner à ce territoire
saint quentin en yvelines est un
véritable bassin d'emploi mais aussi
d'études supérieures cent quarante cinq
mille travailleurs apportent chaque jour
leurs compétences aux entreprises de la
région
pendant que dix sept mille étudiants se
forment sur les bancs de l'une des
universités ou des grandes écoles de la
communauté d'agglomération pôle
d'excellence d'innovation mais aussi de
formation les superlatifs ne manquent
pas la jeune université paris saclay
regroupe à elle seule dix grandes écoles
cet organisme de recherche et deux
universités
mais si les besoins des entreprises en
main d'oeuvre qualifiée sont énormes
encore faut-il que les formations
dispensées correspondent aux besoins des
employeurs à l'université de saint
quentin en yvelines
on a trouvé la parade
les acteurs se communique participe
pleinement à la vie à la gouvernance de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
nous les associons dans notre conseil
d'administration ça de l'université dans
les conseils des facultés dans les
conseils de perfectionnement de façon à
pouvoir recueillir
dans l'ensemble de leurs de leurs
besoins de leur retour sur l'évolution
de nos formations et nous adaptons nos
formations justement à ces besoins de
façon à privilégier l'employabilité des
étudiants à l'issue de leur cursus autre
contexte
autre stratégie depuis 35 ans l'estaca
était implantée à levallois-perret en
août 2015 cette école d'ingénieurs
spécialisée dans les systèmes de
transport des ménages pour 50 ans
territoire fortement marqué par
l'industrie automobile et aéronautique
pour pascal ribot la directrice de
l'école le choix du dieu était une
évidence
ça nous paraissait assez naturel de
venir nous installer sur ce territoire
on y avait des partenaires importants
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines mais aussi des partenaires plus
émergent comme l'institut pour la
transition énergétique vd comme on
voulait aussi rejoindre la communauté de
l'université paris saclay dans lequel
nous avons aussi beaucoup de partenaires
académiques ont beaucoup de partenaires
industriels
il suffit de citer renault psa thales
apprend pour nous c'était un petit peu
comme rejoindre notre famille venir
s'installer ici
grâce à ses nombreux partenariats signés
avec les entreprises de son secteur
désormais situé à quelques encablures
l'école d'ingénieurs peut créer des
programmes pédagogiques
hors les murs de l'école plutôt que
d'étudier le sujet de façon théorique en
salle de cours un enseignant il va
emmener ses étudiants dans l'entreprise
et donc les étudiants pourront
travailler comme s'il était dans
l'équipe d'ingénieurs au sein de
l'entreprise en question souvent les pme
ont
on peut avoir du mal à mobiliser des
centres de recherche des ingénieurs un
certain niveau pour traiter des
problèmes peu compliqué et donc on
espère voir se développer des stages
dans ces pme du territoire qui petit à
petit
on nous connaître et donc nous même
participer au développement économique
et au développement industriel de ces
pme via nos étudiants au sein de
l'université paris saclay lu vs qu
possède une particularité elle fait
partie des universités qui enregistre le
plus fort taux d'étudiants en
apprentissage de france en effet 20% de
ses élèves ont choisi cette voie
et pour cause le dispositif de
l'alternance permet en fait une
meilleure insertion professionnelle
puisque près de 80 % des élèves qui
suivent une formation en alternance vont
trouver un emploi dans les six mois qui
suivent l'obtention de leur diplôme à
peu près un tiers sont recrutés par les
entreprises même qui les ont en tant
qu'apprenti mais indépendamment de leur
formation les étudiants ont tous une
même chance celle de se trouver au coeur
d'un véritable vivier d'entreprises
intéressées par des profils les plus
divers en tant qu'employeur on a un
regard particulièrement vigilants et
intéressés sur les questions de la
formation sur les étudiants et leur
qualification lors de nos process de
recopie elle pas termes de perspectives
le projet paris-saclay reste pour nous
un élément déterminant et légitime
d'autant plus notre présence dans les
yvelines à plaisir au coeur de ces
projets en développement sur ce grand
territoire
ils sont nombreux à miser sur
l'entrepreneuriat comme moteur de
relance de l'économie
encouragez-les envie d'entreprendre et
ce dès les études c'est ce que propose
lui vs qu d'entrepreneurs et a fait
partie des priorités de l'université de
versailles saint quentin
alors pour les étudiants ça veut dire
très concrètement les faire travailler
sur des projets de création d'entreprise
et qui vont ensuite peuvent être
réalisés sur le territoire
ça peut être aussi la possibilité de
s'inscrire
ce qu'on appelle ou diplôme étudiants
entrepreneurs
après la fin de leurs études de pouvoir
bénéficier du statut d'étudiant et de
pouvoir bénéficier d'un accompagnement
d'un coaching pour mener à bien leur
projet de création d'entreprise à
l'estaca on parie beaucoup sur un autre
projet celui d'un incubateur ou de
jeunes créateurs de start-up pourrait
lancer leur activité tout en bénéficiant
de conseils d'experts de soutien
logistique et financier la caisse qui a
un projet d'incubateur c'est vraiment
des sujets sur lequel on peut travailler
ensemble pour la porter les projets qui
permettent de faire sortir de notre
école de probablement aussi d'autres
écoles des entrepreneurs nous c'est des
choses qu'on n'est pas capable de porter
tout seul
investissement serait beaucoup trop
lourd mais travailler avec la casse qui
sur cette thématique là je pense que ces
sont des choses très fructueuse
incubateur prêt à taux zéro dureau
unique de renseignements pour les
entrepreneurs
la caisse qui développe différents
projets visant à faire de ce territoire
un espace d'expérimentation économique
et d'innovation et à favoriser la venue
de nouveaux investisseurs
une de ces mesures vient tout juste de
voir le jour
le small business act ou comment créer
du lien entre les entreprises
le small business act qui est dans fait
de d'inciter les gros a plus travaillé
que les petits également que les
administrations puissent travailler des
petits parce que souvent ils ont de
telles contraintes de telles normes que
les petits nés ils n'osent même plus
postuler pour avec une grosse
administration
donc c'est ça le faisait ces deux
stimuler à ce que tout le monde puisse
travailler tous les niveaux parce
qu'entre gros en fait on fait on est
tous les petits premier pôle commercial
des yvelines l'agglomération ne voit pas
cette palme au hasard si elle se hisse
sur la première marche du podium
c'est parce que le territoire regorge de
centres commerciaux comme celui ci où
rivalisent de nombreuses enseignes
internationales
avec l'élargissement ce sont pas moins
de treize centres commerciaux qui
s'ajoutent aux deux déjà existants les
alpes à park one night in paris le
village des loisirs paris ouest ou
encore grand plaisir des centaines de
milliers de mètres carrés à disposition
des aficionados du shopping cependant de
nombreux commerces de proximité résiste
encore et toujours à l'envahisseur et
avec eux un peu d'hommes au coeur de ces
nouvelles vives
l'intérêt pour les habitants de trouver
du commerce de proximité c'est d'avoir à
la porte de chez eux ou
au pied de leur bureau un savoir faire
spécifique souvent artisanales
c'est trouver des produits de qualité
trouver un accueil des conseils du
service
c'est tout ce que les gens ne trouvent
pas forcément dans les grands centres
commerciaux
et comme pour tous les acteurs socio
économiques du territoire l'arrivée des
cinq nouvelles communes au 1er janvier
2016 apporte son lot d'opportunités et
de défis l'élargissement du territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines
ça offre aux commerçants de proximité
comme aux grandes enseignes nationales
un potentiel client plus large plus
vaste faut-il encore pour nous
commerçants de proximité relevé
le défi de la notoriété de l'image est
arrivé à faire venir dans nos enseignes
aussi bien les gens qui vivent sur saint
quentin en yvelines que les personnes
qui viennent y travailler faire réussir
tous les entrepreneurs du territoire
élargi valoriser les compétences à très
haute valeur ajoutée les grandes écoles
les universités promouvoir le
développement économique l'innovation et
bien évidemment l'emploi
voilà les objectifs désignés comme
prioritaires par et pour la casse qui un
programme exaltant pour un territoire en
mouvement sky mag c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui rendez vous le mois prochain
pour un nouveau numéro
d'ici là portez vous bien